[Music]
7xs is a comedian from Fergus Falls
Minnesota whose new album you're the
best was released today and who's free
one-hour special as is premieres at
midnight on laughs spin dot-com please
welcome the very funny Chad Daniels
[Music]
[Applause]
okay before we get started I just want
to say it is my mom's birthday next week
so happy birthday mom they do care they
do care
I brought her mom out to eat my grandma
to eat for lunch one day and she used
the phrase Jude him down and I said what
in the hell is wrong with you but no one
heard my grandma say Jude him down they
just heard me yell at an old lady
so people are mad like what's going on
over here and I was like oh she's racist
one guy goes maybe that's how she was
raised okay but she has been raised
she's 82
she has risen another guy goes can't
teach an old dog new tricks but yes you
can because I had an old dog once we
taught it specifically how not to say
Jude him down
we're like speak except for that one
thing your German Shepherd that would be
weird
find anything you own poop nine of
Venus's my first girlfriend in college
was black yeah we're making out one
night and she said whisper something
crazy in my ear so I said
and then she said we did it for eight
months and we're still friends and I
think that's because we had great
communication I'd say something she
wouldn't like it and she'd go mm-hmm
like okay she did not like what I just
said but it also sounded like jaws was
right behind me
especially if she'd walk at me she'd be
like a shark behind me it's a very scary
situation to be in because I don't know
she was going to jump in and help
because lots of black people don't like
to swim in the ocean if you're black and
you're mad that I said that stop telling
your white friends stuff you don't want
them to repeat because that is where I
got that information if you were white
and you were nervous that I said that
don't be I chose those words very
carefully I said lots of black people
not all I said don't like to swim in the
ocean not camped
and that would be racist if you are
Asian or Hispanic mind your own business
that wasn't about you not everything's
always about you
some things are black and white only I
[Applause]
have two kids my son is 12 and he's kind
of got that 12 year old boy attitude now
I brought him to the movie theater and I
got him a beverage and popcorn
combination and he goes hey dad can you
get an extra straw and I said for what
and he goes your saliva so then I
reminded him he came from the inside of
my penis I don't have a lot of rules at
my house but one of them is you do not
get to have a problem with my bodily
fluids if you used to be one of them
my daughter is 8 and she came home from
school and and she goes hey Dad
Stacey and I were playing catch and she
hit me right in the balls she's up she
only has an older brothers he's only
heard this area referred to as the ball
a good dad would tell her that she's
wrong I'm not going to do that I have
chosen to use that to my advantage to be
on her first date making out with some
dude and she'd be like
guess who's done making out until at
least college cuz now everyone in high
schools think she has balls you guys
were great thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]